Oh
so this talk is called all this useless
beauty and it's about surreal numbers in
JavaScript so it's kind of a tricky
topic and it's not particularly useful
it's nice to get this over with so we
can get on with actual useful stuff that
will make you better developers for the
rest of the day yeah as John mentioned
I'm a teacher so this is the kind of
thing I try and get my students
interested in rather than just how to
make money doing web stuff I'm not
really a social media kind of guy but
you can find me on snapchat my username
is crud head and I'm also called head on
IRC if any of you ever run into me that
and I'm from Sydney so these slides
obviously this is just the plug for my
sponsor here this is revealed j/s it
doesn't look like usual reveal jazz but
I don't want you to think that I
actually have design skills I've
actually ripped this design off from jen
Schiffer I haven't even renamed the
files its source to references to jquery
conference in austin texas of last year
but I met her last year and she's
wonderful she talks about the same kinds
of things except her stuff is much more
beautiful obviously and I'd encourage
you to go and look up some of her talks
what I have added to this is my own
picture here which is Harvey Birdman
there was a complaint from some people
that I didn't include enough pictures in
my slides so I put Harvey Birdman on
every single page there and if you get
bored you can just look a Harvey Birdman
I like to think that he's kind of
looking at my slides and quietly
approving of them so he got to slide to
himself there this presentation contains
one animated gif I know that you young
developing people like animated gifts so
I've got one in here it's not a funny
one but if you're a fan of animated gifs
you can look forward to that
so where do I come from I'm not famous
I'm just one of the regular kind of guys
that r is interested in web stuff I
haven't ever done anything famous I'm
much older than all of you at least
spiritually so I was doing this stuff
last century before most of your born
before nine eleven I like to think of it
and I was making the internet and it was
all going fine and then I'd know exactly
sure what happened but something called
the dot-com collapsed and lots of people
didn't have work for a while so I went
to university and I thought I'll study
mathematics that's got something to do
with computers probably and that stuff's
really hard and don't don't study
mathematics don't let your children do
it I really regret having done that I
discovered it there towards the end of
my seven-year failing first you mats for
x degree that jQuery is quite fun so
Java scripts not my favorite language
you can beat me up for that later but
I'd really like the community I like the
community I like JavaScript because of
you people that come to things like this
I like the jQuery IRC channel I like
jQuery because it makes it easy for
people to do cool stuff that they're
excited about so that got me back into
the web and I ended up teaching so I
worked for a number of years doing that
and it turned out it's easier to teach
people if you can speak easy to teach
and actually make things because I
didn't have deadlines my students come
to me they say the projects due on
Friday I'm not gonna get this finished
and it's not my problem I just say good
luck with that
so what I learned at University this is
a you know a brief summary maths is
really hard and it's very impressive
that some people are good at it I'm not
one of those people I especially hate
calculus I didn't realize those going to
be so much I should have seen that
coming but it's just one of those things
I especially hate infinitesimals so I
side with Bishop Berkeley when calculus
was kind of invented or discovered we'll
talk a bit more about that in a moment
he wrote a letter complaining that
infinitesimals were offensive to God so
you guys know with the area under a
curve you can work it out by taking an
infinite number of infinitely small
things and they add up to the area under
the curve that makes me feel icky I
really don't like that it doesn't make
sense I know it works i'm happy that it
works but i don't i don't want to have
anything to do with it so I'm with
Berkeley that that is horrible and it
turns out what I should have studied is
these fields called the philosophy of
mathematics and or meta mathematics so
that's the stuff about how math works
rather than actually having to deal with
the nitty gritty details so the kinds of
questions you get to talk about in the
philosophy of mathematics do numbers
exist is mathematics invented or
discovered would we have mathematics if
we didn't have people how do written
symbols capture mathematical truths what
the hell is truth I took too long
courses on what truth is I still don't
know but it's it's an interesting
question more relevant is how well do
computers model mathematics and we'll
talk about that in a little bit and
questions like how does girdles
incompleteness theorem affect our daily
lives I'm not sure that it does but it's
fun to think about so what I try to
teach what I'm teaching three months at
a time of a full-stack web development
bootcamp kind of thing that's all the
rage these days so I teach people how to
make web stuff the full stack as they
say and you know my motivation is that
I'm trying to hire I'm trying to teach
people to have the kinds of skills that
I would hire them for so if they showed
up on day 1 i'd be able to give them
something to do and they be able to do
something useful for me but beyond that
i take it as an opportunity to teach
people about the joy of programming
because i really love this stuff i just
got into
computers when as a kid and I've never
really had a wobble about what I do with
my career that's just worked out well
for me so I try and teach them stuff
that like this isn't anything to do with
money this is just interesting or fun so
the things that I insist that they
should know the things I say when you
have some spare time this is what you
should go and look up I think they
should learn formal logic I think there
is not enough emphasis on formal logic
in computer science courses and I think
it makes us stronger developers it makes
development more easily if you're able
to understand reasoning that kind of
abstract thought and I also think you
should learn regular expressions because
everyone should learn regular
expressions I mean obviously especially
developers but I'm often shocked to
discover that people who are senior to
me in companies don't know regular
expressions and come to me for help with
what the hell is matter with you people
these things will save you time so you
know I tell my students you need to
learn regular expressions why I think
formal logic matters in computing so you
guys know about cheering machines um you
don't have to know how to make them but
you know that what they are the idea was
you know ensuring invented this who's
like how would I automate the process as
I go through when I'm trying to think of
some think through some problem so it's
like a machine that does the job that a
mathematician or a logicians brain would
do so Turing machines are basically
mechanical reasons they can do reasoning
mechanically for you and computers that
we use today are practical cheering
machines we kind of we wouldn't have
computers in this state if we hadn't had
the concept of a Turing machine first
computers are also formal systems so if
you're able to think about formal logic
and formal systems then that gives you a
sense of what your computer is doing and
I like to think that a computer is a
tiny frantic robot logician trapped
inside these machines so if you think of
them in those terms it's easier to push
them around so this is about two real
numbers but I'll give you a little bit
of context for this numbers is really
strange and children understand this you
forget about it because you just get
used to them you can pay your bus fare
or pay your rent each month or whatever
else needs to do but when you explain
what numbers are the children they
understand that numbers are quite
strange and I like to encourage people
to go back to think about this and kind
of be weirded out by numbers so for
example does the number seven exist and
if so where is it is the number seven in
this room somewhere with the number
seven exist if people didn't exist
hand on the physical universe in some
way it's an interesting but you know
obviously we can use the number seven
and whether or not we believe in it it's
not an important question but it's an
interesting one where did the number
come from where is it going what does it
want we're actually relying on numbers
but we don't really know what they are
and I mean I've thought about this a lot
and I still don't know what they are and
most mathematicians it turns out don't
want to talk about this they just want
to get on with it they ask you to stop
asking questions and please leave the
university but if you're if you're in
the philosophy department they will
agree with you that foundations of
mathematics are still uncertain so
there's quote from John von Neumann he
of the von Neumann architecture which
are machines today using mathematics you
don't understand things you just get
used to them and that's really true we
just get used to mathematics we kind of
ignore how weird it all is so let's
consider the number 144 in decimal
that's expressed with one and a four and
four that's what it looks like in binary
and that's the JavaScript version
because JavaScript doesn't want to do
binary as a literal that's the octal
version and that's the hexadecimal
version so these things all represent
the number that we call in decimal or
base 10 144 but they're not the actual
number ok go to keep that in mind
they're just different representations
of this thing whatever it is wherever it
is the number 144 and these basically
just symbols which behave like the
number they do the things that we expect
the number 144 to dirt it's greater than
100 it's divisible by 2 and so on so
numbers in JavaScript I put some
JavaScript in here because that's why
you guys are here so it seemed like the
right thing to do programs generally
model numbers as collections of ones and
zeros so you know that computers really
binary that's what they're insured and
JavaScript as you know uses the I eeee
754 double precision binary
floating-point format which gives us
most of the values we care about so we
can count lots and lots of integers and
we get some rough approximation of a
bunch of decimals so in JavaScript this
is what 144 looks like in the computer's
memory at 64 bits and there's a couple
little ones in there and then a whole
bunch of zeros and there's some problems
with this which are fairly famous
problems you will have heard about these
so we have
Robbins with overflow and underflow and
precision so to give you some examples
in JavaScript this is the biggest number
you can talk about or think about just
using native JavaScript so you can
access number max value tell you what
the biggest number is and that's it and
it's a huge number but if you ever
needed a bigger number you can't do it
in JavaScript we also have this problem
this is the integers if you're just
counting integers as soon as you get up
to this big old number here and add one
to it you just get the same number back
which is not a great thing for a
language that's doing mathematics to do
that shouldn't be true but it is in
JavaScript you'll also have heard about
this one point two plus point one
doesn't give you point three gives you a
point three and a little tiny bit extra
so I e75 for is an imperfect model you
can do a bunch of mathematics but you
can't do all that but it's of Isis so
can we model numbers in a different way
and it turns out that yes we can so
let's talk about sets this is a terrible
pun and I'm sorry for that fortunately
you're too young to know what I'm
talking about so I've stolen Wikipedia
definition of what a set is here they're
very easy to understand in mathematics a
set is a collection of distinct objects
considered as an object in its own right
so we say that there's a thing as a set
it's a collection of things so sets
usually delimited with curly braces like
that and for example here's the set of
positive primes less than 10 so that's
two three five and seven to find how to
put the numbers into the set and then
I've actually gone ahead and drop them
straight in there so here's some
interesting sets that doesn't just have
to be math related so there's the set of
people in this room right at this moment
that's a valid set that's a thing you
can talk about you can think about you
can reason about it there's the set of
Paul Irish there's the set of odd
integers and that's an infinite set as
infinitely many audiences and you can
still put them in a set you can have
infinite sets that's fine there's a set
of things that don't exist which is also
an infinite set and it's a very big one
and I quite like thinking about it the
set of things that don't exist seems to
be much much much bigger than the set of
things that do exist
and you can have the set of odd numbers
and a set of sorry the set of the set of
odd numbers and the set of even numbers
so sets can contain other sets that's
not a problem either and we've got this
concept called cardinality so the
cardinality of a set s is the number of
members of s so for example if we have a
set B which has three colors in it blue
white and red then the cardinality of
that set is three this is easy right
this you can teach this stuff to primary
school kids so cardinality the
interesting thing about it why I care
about it is because we can use it as a
source for natural numbers and so it's a
way of generating natural numbers it's a
place where numbers can be derived from
so the number seven for example you can
say that that is the cardinality of all
sets with seven members so if we want to
say does the number seven exist we can
say sure you just take all of the sets
that have exactly seven members and it's
the cardinality of those sets it's the
number of things in them and so here's
some headache-inducing sets so I'm just
focus on Harvey Birdman if this is too
much for you these ones are the tricky
ones that keep people awake at night so
we have this set of all sets that is a
big old set and an interesting property
of the set of all sets is that it
includes itself right because it's also
a set we have also the set of all sets
that include themselves which is another
one's that they'll make your brain hurt
so the set of all sets does include
itself so it's included in the set of
all sets that include themselves and
Russell's paradox the set of all sets
that don't include themselves so for
example the set of Paul Irish doesn't
include itself it's just got
polarization and it doesn't have any
other sets in it does Russell's set
include itself so does the set of all
sets that don't include themselves
include itself or not and the answer is
yes and not because as soon as it
includes itself you need to remove it
from the set but as soon as you remove
it you need to put it back into the set
so this bar Bertrand Russell was trying
to establish that mathematics worked
really well and had a solid basis in set
theory and then this burned him are you
kind of had a breakdown about this
because you found this set that you just
couldn't really deal with in a nice way
so there's paradoxes of the heart of set
theory you just can't get away from that
so now we're going to deal with a much
nicer set one that's much easier to
think about is the empty set so all the
sets that we've talked about so far have
relied on external objects we needed
things elsewhere in the world or in the
platonic realm or something to put into
the sets so it's likely people in this
room that's we were relying on notice to
define what that set was but there's an
interesting set with no members and it
doesn't rely on anything and that's
called the empty set so that's just the
true curlies with nothing inside of it
so we can derive this set in various
ways it's easy to show people that the
empty set exists the set of porsches the
iron ore will ever learn is an empty set
the set of numbers that is less than 10
and greater than 20 obviously there's no
number that is both less than 10 and
greater than 20 so that is also an empty
set and we just think of that as being
the empty set in all of these cases it's
the same set its the empty set is set
with nothing in it we can use the empty
set to produce numbers that's why
mathematicians and logicians like it
they can use the empty set as a basis
for mathematics so they can derive the
number three from the cardinality of the
set with 3m avec with three empty sets
inside of it so there's a set inside it
has three empty sets I can produce the
number three I can say well obviously
the number three exists because it's the
cardinality of this set and doesn't
depend on anything else so you need to
say is that sets exist and the empty set
exists and we can get the number three
out of it so several formalization of
the foundations of mathematics proofs
that mathematics has a rigorous
foundation we're actually talking about
something and not just hallucinating you
can use this as a way of doing it and
it's it lots of different formalization
have done that so the thrill numbers I'm
about to finally talk about are using
this idea they're using a variation of
this idea so we'll get on to those so
surreal numbers they're not actually
useful nobody would ever do this in real
life and I did it in real life and I
kind of regret it but I get to talk to
you about it now it's from these this
area of recreational mathematics which
is also called armchair mathematics
or our mathematical games and Douglas
Hofstadter called it meta magical femurs
which for anagram fans is an anagram of
mathematical games so that it's implicit
in here that is not of any particular
use it's just interesting to think about
and surreal numbers were invented by
John Conway and I picked this picture of
him because he looks quite depraved in
there I kind of like that about him and
Harvey Birdman likes it too you will
have heard of Conway because you'll have
heard of Conway's Game of Life and this
is not JavaScript this is actually an
animated gif so I'll leave that one for
a second for you to enjoy but obviously
Conway is a time waster right he's
interested in the game of life which has
no real practical usage and he's
interested in serial numbers so that
that's kind of his his schtick is like
things that are interesting but don't
matter I first heard about us real
numbers from Donald Knuth which makes it
sound like I know him personally I've
never met the guy but he's written a
book about it he's known as the author
of the art of computer programming which
I told my students to read because it's
currently five volumes long and about
this wide and no mother get to the
bottom of it Bill Gates once said that
if anybody had actually read the whole
thing they should apply to him directly
for a job I don't know if he still says
that but he did but Donald truth also
wrote this book surreal numbers and I
don't remember how I first heard about
this book because I didn't know there's
going to be a big deal to me so I didn't
make a note of it he wrote this book in
the 70s and you'll see how 70s is in
when I show you the subtitle how to X
students turned on to pure mathematics
and found total happiness which is very
70s they also enjoy the cover which I
believe his wife true that's two people
sitting on a beach having a chat about
surreal numbers and those that that
particular color scheme is also very
very 70s it's not a good book it's it's
not a bit it's not written as a textbook
the whole thing is written as a dialogue
between these two starstruck lovers
sitting on this beach somewhere on the
coast and there are they just invent
surreal numbers or discovers real
numbers as something to do it's
interesting if you're interested in
serial numbers but I wouldn't go to it
if you're looking at putting on a play
for your local theater company
something like that so surreal numbers
this is how they work so your numbers
are made up of sets of other sets so
surreal number is a set with some other
sets inside of it and we make new
numbers by taking existing numbers when
putting those in new sets and in a
second you'll see how horrible the
syntax for this is the notation but you
should be able to get the idea of how it
works so each set has two members what
we call a left and a right so this is
what it looks like this is the template
for a surreal number it's a set with two
spaces in two slots in it into which
we're going to insert other sets while
this real numbers so to get things
started you have to define the first
serial number and this is what it looks
like it's that's the number zero and
it's a set with two empty sets inside of
it so the left part of it is an empty
set and the right part of it is also an
empty set so that's a given that's it
and an axiom of the system once you've
got that we can make everything else
work so this is the number one what we
do is we put in the left-hand slot we
put the number 0 which we defined
earlier I've marked it in blue there so
you can see that it's just that same
symbol again and the right-hand side is
just the empty set and make it a little
bit more readable we usually write it in
that way we write the number 0 meaning
the real number which represents 0 which
we've already defined that goes in the
left slot and the empty set in the right
we also got minus 1 which we do the same
thing we put it into the right slot
rather than the left slot so here the
left slot has the empty set in it and
the right slot has the number 0 which
looks like that and then this is where
you can see how it starts to get hideous
this is the number two where we take the
existing number one and put that into
the left slot and we leave the right
slow to learn so it still has the empty
set and marked in blue in the middle
there you can still see the original
zero so we have a zero and that's used
to produce one which then is used to
produce it too and you would write that
in that syntax you'd say the number that
represents one sets that represent one
going the left slot and the empty set on
the right and minus two we do the same
thing I left the left set alone and I
put the number minus one in the
right-hand set is that all perfectly
clear haha
so you can also use this to produce
fractions so the fraction here we take
the number zero put that in the left
slot and the number one goes in the
right spot you can produce a quarto by
taking the half and sticking that in the
right-hand side and you can produce an
eight by taking a quarter and putting
that in the right hand side and so on
and you can keep doing that to get
successive powers of two so if you do
this forever what you actually produce
and people who are much smarter than me
have proved that this is correct you can
get the entire continuum of real numbers
so that means all of the numbers that
we're familiar with the real numbers are
all going to have a space a
representation in this real number
system it might be you know thousands
and thousands of sets of empty sets but
it's possible it can be done and this
real numbers have various interesting
properties which is why mathematicians
are interested in them so for example
the surreal numbers contains more
numbers than our actual real number
system there's some bonus stuff that you
get for free if you use this system
there's some numbers that you can
express as surreal numbers that you
can't express in any other way and they
still behave like numbers you can still
do all the usual mathematical stuff one
interesting example is you have
different sizes for the number infinity
or just have positive infinity you've
got different sizes of infinity and
they're all infinite but some of them
are more infinite than others no
seriously so this is this is an image
which should make it all perfectly clear
to you it's much too tiny to read but
this is from the wikipedia article and
surreal numbers and it shows how you
start from zero and you keep producing
more numbers in terms of the numbers
you've already got and you see down the
bottom it gets very thick it means we've
filled out the number like we've got all
these numbers in that so my stupid idea
was to implement surreal numbers in
JavaScript using empty arrays as empty
sets and as few real numbers as possible
I want to see how far I could get
without using any actual real numbers
just trying to do the whole thing
bootstrapping or surreal numbers so
that's what 0 looks like on the first
day conway created 0 and that's how
array with two empty arrays in it and
what would this mean if i got this
working every real number could be
represented so we wouldn't have the
limitations of current javascript
numbers you could go up as high as you
wanted it go as low as you wanted you
could get very small numbers
all the fractions and everything would
work properly you wouldn't have the
rounding errors that we saw before when
we add point 1 to point 2 there's also
no fear of underutilizing your memory
your own because these things are arrays
of a raise if you've got a macbook with
eight gig of ram in it you can very
easily exhaust that memory just by using
fairly small numbers and beyond that
there's no need to restart your browser
periodically surreal numbers will do
that for you by crashing the browser
entirely so if that's what you're
looking for in a number system this is a
solution for you so how far did I get
with this I've got natural numbers in it
that was a nice surprise to get that
working I can now if I have you know
very very powerful machine I can count
up to infinity I've got all the integers
that means i can count down to minus
infinity that works well are also given
you know infinite computer power so in
theory i can go up as high as positive
infinity but of course it will crash
long before it gets there I've managed
to go from an integer so I can take an a
you know normal human number and convert
that into any surreal number and I can
go the other way I can get the integer
version back and I've got the quality
working which I'm quite pleased about so
i can say where the true surreal numbers
are equal I've also got the comparisons
working so i can say where the two
numbers are less than or less than or
equal to or greater than or greater than
or equal to that all worked really
nicely so some of the code I was
surprised by how beautiful this turned
out to be you probably can't read that
especially well there but what I've got
is the is equal to i define that by
saying a number is equal to another
number if it's both less than or equal
to the other number and greater than or
equal to the other number if both of
those conditions are true if it's both
less than or equal to and greater than
or equal to I know it must actually be
equal to so the test for equality is
just that one single single statement in
that single function now so that was a
nice surprise and the rest of the
comparisons are really nice as well I've
got is less than is defined by saying
it's not greater than or equal to I to
work out if something is greater than or
equal to I just work out if it's the
other way holds that the other number is
less than or equal to this number
is greater than it's just the same as
the first case I say if it's not less
than or equal to so that's all really
nice that's very short amount of code
you'll see though that I've only got
three of the comparisons in here and you
know that there are four and the reason
I've put this on a separate slide this
is my beautiful code this is my
nightmare code so to make all of this
work all the other ones I could define
in terms of this one this one actually
had to do some work to make it happen
and there's a whole bunch of code in
there I'm not proud of that stuff it
could probably be improved but it gets
crazy to work out which side of zero
you're on and how large numbers are so
if I'd known that was coming I wouldn't
have bothered with this and you wouldn't
be hearing from me today so the things
i'd like to do i haven't learned my
lesson from this i'm still doing this i
think the frustration i have is because
i'm teaching at the moment i'm not
actually making anything new so i'm just
looking for random problems to solve i'd
like to get fractions working there in
the book but i haven't actually
implemented them yet because that's
going to mess up all my existing courage
i also have no arithmetic so i can't
actually add or multiply or divide any
of these numbers yet i can just make
them exist and count with them but
that's all so you can see this code for
yourself i put it up on github my
username on github is called head and
it's surreal jeaious there's no fancy
test suites or anything like that it's
just my file with 170 lines of code that
implements the serial numbers but what I
would argue is that it's better to do
this stuff yourself you don't I don't
think I'd make this library because
somebody be like oh that's good i need
an implementation of surreal numbers to
do maths in javascript it's more that it
was highly educational when a lot of fun
to do and i would urge you to go and
have a look at this book it's freely
available in various PDF forms you can
go and read it and have a cracker
implementing it or even just pushing
these things around on pen and paper is
that it's fine so I've got also here a
short list of books if you're interested
in any of this this is the things i
would suggest you read if you're
interested in this topic douglas
hofstadter wrote a couple of books in
the 70s as godel escher bach and eternal
golden braid which is about number
theory and formal systems and where the
computers will ever be able to think
that kind of thing and he also has a
series of essays called meta magical
famous rudy rocker is a computer
scientist and mathematician
titian who also took a lot of drugs and
also wrote a lot of fiction I
particularly recommend his where
tetralogy which is software wetware
freeware and real where which deals with
artificial intelligence and robot rights
and things like that but also the hot
topic of human robot sex which I know a
lot more about now and as an actual
professor he's written a couple of
series books so there's book called mind
tools which is about the fundamentals of
mathematics and how it works and another
book called infinity and the mind which
is about well just what it says really I
also really liked David Foster Wallace's
recent book everything and more concise
history of infinity so these are all pop
books they're not for mathematicians of
people like us who have some interest in
these things everything and more is just
a history of how mathematicians and
magicians have grappled with infinity
I'm also recommending alice in
wonderland with this cute quote from
Alan Perlis the best book on programming
for the layman is Alice in Wonderland
but that's because it's the best book on
anything for the layman and if you don't
agree with that that just means you
haven't read it enough time so you
should go and give that another shot so
what I learned about math so i'll just
quickly sum up with we're actually what
I took away from all of this making math
work is actually really hard you think
that's easy children can count I'll be
able to do this for sure I've got a
textbook to help me and it's not like
that it actually turns out to be much
trickier than I expected especially if
you have to build your own numbers so if
you're not using any of javascripts
numbers behind the scenes if you're
doing all yourself you appreciate how
much is going on that when you get it to
work it is incredibly satisfying when
you create a giant number you've got an
integer and you say give me the serial
number version of this and then you say
what's the real number but the integer
version of this and get it back the
other way that is satisfying in a way I
wasn't expecting particularly as it's
not actually useful it was just like
I've got this hard problem to solve and
then I fixed it but what I especially
have realized is you can't take your
number implementation for granted so if
maths works in your programming language
that's really a big deal people have put
some hard work in there to make that
happen for you so if something works you
should hug an implementer and we have
Dave here if anyone wants hugs later and
how it feels about that but you can
negotiate that with him
what I learned about programming these
particular problems this is this is new
stuff for me I hadn't solved this
particular problem for before and this
involved an incredible amount of staring
into the distance lots of walks around
the harbor just thinking about how the
hell I'm going to get the next bit
working and it didn't look like I was
working but I was working really hard
the old fashioned pen and paper approach
goes a long way with these kinds of
things where possible it's good to get
anger scroll from Twitter to review your
code he's available on Twitter and I
don't know just asking just send him
your your reviews maybe we'll do it he
did it for me and finally what I learned
about the big stuff it's good to break
your habits and get out of your comfort
zone so as web developers were used to
doing web stuff and we tend to see
everything in in terms of you know Dom
manipulations or if we're not developers
we think about streams all the time it's
good to just do something that isn't of
useful used to your isn't necessarily
part of your daily life just as mental
exercise and it's you know people say
don't reinvent the wheel you can
reinvent the wheel you can make stranger
wheels you can make wheels that don't
work as well as the existing wheel the
existing wheel is pretty good but you
can learn some interesting stuff by
making bizarre new kind of alien wheels
that nobody needs but also I got this
nice sense that wonders never cease so
the more I've looked into the theory of
mathematics and how it all works the
more surprised and kind of delighted I
am there's all this magical stuff that
exists somewhere I don't know how it
works and all these strange properties
arise from like surreal numbers or
whatever else you want to look into um
but overall I would argue for making
beautiful and useless things just as
something to do it's immensely
satisfying it might not help you get a
job but you know do it for yourself and
that's all I've got I won't be taking
questions because I don't know the
answers but thank you very much
if we can put our hands together patrol
again also i have a round of applause to
Harvey Birdman who was pivotal in that
presentation